i don't know that he would have been
bold enough
to sorry this hat
i just
popped out
hello
the 2000s no i i think you have the
wrong number
yeah okay let's do that
[Music]
hey curly um i heard a rumor that you
like ultra low rise jeans emmy are we
gonna time warp back to the 2000s yes
curly so
let's go shopping yes let's do it okay
wait when's your birthday what's your
sign i'm virgo september 5th
i'm also a virgo but i'm august 29th
we need to find you an early 2000s
moment yes i'm so excited i feel like a
best absolutely right i mean like this
is serving me like avril lavigne
skater boy i think i had one vest that i
wore constantly were you like a theater
musical kid i was actually an athlete
first oh sure yeah
soccer tennis center on track that's hot
how do you go from sports to i was a
really loud kid first of all and anytime
my parents would have a dinner party i
would stand on the coffee table and put
on a performance so they're like we have
to get this kid in the theater did you
go to like a public school private
school public school is it like an
umbrella academy sort of thing or
no it was very much public school
amazing i feel like we need to add a pop
of cool air you know what i'm saying
yeah
oh stop it
yes
people were stepping on necks for
t-shirts with this little alligator i
had no idea that that was that popular
one in high school and my dad gave me
one and i shredded it in the back
i did not
i was like
[Laughter]
it was like this was the ultimate like
yacht boy because i grew up by the water
uh-huh so it was like a lacoste t-shirt
khaki shorts and like a sperry's i
wanted to ask you about umbrella academy
yes yes so this is season three season
three and you're number three 33 is a
really good angel number wait i never
even thought about that yeah i'm a
weirdo my brain just works differently
you're kind of like known for your
fashion in it too like you're bringing
the looks i try to bring the look do you
have a lot of say in what you get to
wear yeah our costume designer
christopher hardin is incredible are
there any exciting looks coming up this
season yeah there's some incredible new
characters and so we're introducing a
whole new family of villains and they
all get to wear like unbelievable like
leather super suits i love that on the
first day of set when we all 14 of us
were there together and they came out in
their like leather super suits like the
umbrellas we never got those yeah and we
were like wait a minute hold on
they actually look like real superheroes
and we just feel like the jeep watered
down version in street clothes which
honestly story of my life i'm always the
one that looks like a watered down
superhero and she closed also i heard
you make out with your brother in the
show
well okay
[Laughter]
you guys are like in the same house
we're all adopted so technically no
we're not blood related yeah but you
know family is family chosen or not did
you play any fun games in high school
yes what is that this is a fortune
teller um this is a little bit more
junior high-ish for those of you who
don't know do you want to pick a color
yeah oh my gosh okay i like green
green's my favorite i like green i love
e
g-r-e-e-n
yes wow i forgot for a second pick a
number five my favorite number i love
number five one two three four five
pick a number three four three
yes number three oh god
oh may you get more money to buy me a
house
[Laughter]
did you ever play those other games like
seven minutes in heaven and all those
things no i think spin the bottle was
still definitely a big one i tried
playing the bottle too but nobody ever
wanted to make out with me i had my
first note so it's like honey those lips
also paid for
i feel like we need a denim
definitely need these
[Laughter]
oh my god bring it all back speaking of
games love a game your new movie yes
hilarious is about a very intense game
yes it is called gatlop the game it's
about a group of friends who come
together for a game night to hope like
try and make one of their friends feel
better post-divorce yes and they start
playing this drinking game
and it gets very intense very quickly
you know someone gets shot in like at
one point like with a bow and arrow yes
it's like it's serving you jumanji it's
serving you dumb and dumber was that
like an intense movie for y'all to shoot
we shot it in 12 days in an airbnb in
2020 like at the height of kovid wow
well i also wanted to ask you in
hamilton yeah yeah since you're my
friend now can i be super honest i've
never i've never seen allison
i love that do you recommend i highly
recommend seeing it live and then
because i know it's on disney plus which
is incredible and that's the original
cast nothing beats live theater live
theater yes and then um what is it about
a lot of people think he was a president
okay he's not
i mean he was the first treasury of
state in america
and it's the story of his life and he
completely changed the structure of our
country it's a story about a treasurer
yes sounds exciting
alrighty should i go try on the clothes
that you chose for me i don't know what
you've been doing i'm waiting wow
it's really below rise that i'm here for
hannah
hey
now i'm going to try my first look yes
did you have a cutie patootie yeah
partner yes do you think that y'all
would have dated in high school i think
i definitely would have been into him in
high school but i don't know that he
would have been bold enough
to sorry this hat
i just
popped out i don't know that he would
have been bold enough to approach me
[Music]
why do you have that look on your face i
look like a factory boy but like now oh
i mean
that's all of them
[Music]
so you were yeah i think i was like a
theater nerd i went to a performing arts
high school so for the first part of my
day i went to my actual high school and
then i was put on a bus with a bunch of
other kids and then we went to an arts
nerd school and so i think a lot of
people at my home school my actual high
school like didn't understand they're
like where do you go after one and i was
like i go to this magical place where we
learn to sing and dance all day we talk
about barbara streisand and fatty lafone
oh my god what did i say earlier and
like a sperry's oh it's berries oh okay
also that they didn't do that but listen
you're bringing it into today honey okay
2022.
i forgot about the double shirt that's
the one thing that hasn't come back that
i'm really okay with that can stay away
you gotta pop a collar oh
god i'm probably fighting your beach
town
this is not bad at all
um
it's not
i
am undone
those are so large
and the boxers
those are mine
wait the belt the sweat bands
[Music]
this is my favorite one i think you have
captured the essence of the high school
experience you clearly need and want to
be in a music video
[Music]
clearly this has been so fun but i heard
a rumor that i have to go save the world
yes please so by all means yeah the
world needs saving but keep that okay
keep all of that yes anything for you
always
i love you this is a look that i'm not
sure that i would wear now but i would
have worn then for sure if you would
have gone out to a club back in the day
looking like this you would have been a
lie you would have been it
[Music]
bye